[Music]
NATO members must finally contribute
their fair share and meet their
financial obligations trough was in
Brussels for the NATO summit as I was
saying before and one they were lining
up for one of their photos look at him
get kind of handsy with the prime
minister of Montenegro all right out of
my way
[Music]
they have been fake news for a long time
they've been covering me in a very very
dishonest way do you have that also by
the way mr. president what CNN and and
others said mean I know there's NBC is
equally as bad despite the fact that I
made him a fortune with The Apprentice
but they forgot that
[Music]
numerous reporters noticed that Donald
Trump was not wearing an earpiece for a
whole bunch of Shinzo Abbey's comments
and Trump was nodding along while Shinzo
ABI was speaking as if he understood
Japanese even though obviously he
couldn't understand the word of what was
being said as far as wiretapping I guess
by you know this past administration at
least we have something in common
perhaps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]